alright guys thanks for having me here
let's see so I I'm gonna start out with
just a quick background of where I'm
coming from I was in these seats much
like some of you are here today in fact
I think I was on SCPD for many years as
well so I don't know if I'm gonna get
like the voice of God coming in someone
asked a question that's always fun and
so I'm gonna give you my path coming
here and this is kind of a fun little
thing when I was a small child I loved
computers I had a little Commodore 64 I
had an Amiga I had a 283 6 or 386 at 46
a Pentium Pro I was really proud of this
I decided you know what I want to go
into computers so finished up in 2001
here had a Bachelor of Science and an
electrical engineering I got a master's
in 2004 while I was working over at
Intel and I so I decided I love these
computers I'm gonna design them so I
started working in Itanium division so
the enterprise processor division where
I was working on the Madison and
Montecito processor which at the time
was the largest ship in the world
billion transistors
I guess there's 2 billion in the latest
iPhone so it doesn't mean much anymore
but at the time it was really big and
then it was a 4 year 300 people project
that was for a processor shrink it was
not a new new processor and how about
one of these x86 processors that people
are using these days one in his laptop
well even at the time it was over a
thousand people I was a very small cog
and a very very large machine Itanium
didn't do so well I I knew many people
including all of the press which called
it the I tannic if you'll notice we have
the sales forecasts in blue and as each
year went along they revised the sales
forecast repeatedly and repeatedly and
the actual well
it didn't quite match so well they they
they weren't doing so well
and it becomes well the big picture
matters so here I was working over at
Intel projects failing life is very
nonlinear 98 they'd laid off five
thousand two thousand six they laid off
ten percent of their workforce 2014
another five percent of the workforce it
just kept on going and going and going
and there's they were outsourcing their
people over here they're moving it to to
Taiwan to India as fantastic company by
the way I have no problem with what they
were doing is just they had to do these
these were the market forces the
semiconductors the design costs were
greatly increasing so a number of
projects going down costs just spiraling
up I don't think any of that's changed
it's just this is what I was trained for
this is why I was an electrical engineer
and I could see that there's there's a
lot of problems with the whole field
it's it's a difficult field it's it's
shrinking in some sense and growing at
the same time or been talking to a lot
of people in the chip industry and they
they feel like we're hitting peak
semiconductor in some sense it's a huge
part of what runs the world but
nevertheless it's not growing in the
same rate that it was when I was a kid
so I also want to build stuff I want to
invent things so 2004 I'm gonna change I
could go to a medical school I could do
a more graduate school go to business
school so I decided that all of those
options I wanted to end up in the
healthcare field of some sort Healthcare
seems to be growing pretty rapidly is
very interesting has I have a lot of
personal connections to it is something
that I very much enjoy so grad school
has all of you guys here right now is a
great place to reinvent oneself so I
worked at Berkeley from 2004 to 2010 as
a graduate student starting a new
project which I'll tell you about then I
was a research scientist and I was
running a small lab over there
with fantastic p.i from 2010 to 2014 and
finally in 2012 I started up this
company magnetic insight got funded in
about 2014 and now we here are in 2017
so a bit about spinning out the company
well I'll be honest in 2012 I was burned
out just it had been a very brutal few
years a personal stuff happened my wife
passed away and I've just done
I was out so I started shopping the
technology around I'm like you know I I
can't I can't do this right now so maybe
I can get this technology out I mean
here we are I'm eight or nine years in
developing something I just want the
world to see it I don't want it to be
stuck in some lab somewhere where no one
ever sees the technology so I found a
CEO this was completely happenstance so
here's here's Ana here I get her picture
up here it was completely happenstance I
tried to shop this out to a number of
companies and the leading innovator are
the leading sorry a sales leader in
small animal imaging out on the explain
what we're doing in a little bit is a
company called PerkinElmer and
PerkinElmer is multi-billion dollar
company and we we got the technology
into their hands just just an overview
of what it could do and Ana came to us
and said hey you know we absolutely love
the technology but PerkinElmer we we
don't develop new stuff it's not far
enough for us to license it in and start
shipping product out we expect that to
happen immediately we can't build up a
design team in fact I don't think they
even have any design teams so where do I
go with that well it turns out that she
was going through some personal changes
too so hurt her career was at caliper
and then PerkinElmer had bought caliper
PerkinElmer was a very company and so
she was here in the Bay Area Perkins
over in Massachusetts and so she'd been
flying back and forth and commuting to a
job in Massachusetts so she's like well
hey why don't we just spin this out into
a company maybe PerkinElmer violator who
knows we
we could bring it quite far so that's
how I found a CEO she quit her job
joined the company and all of that
happened in course of just a couple
couple months it was just a it's all
just happenstance didn't expect that to
happen so here we go starting the
company and the company is magnetic in
sight so what we develop is called
magnetic particle imaging so a little
bit of history just about medical
imaging I don't know if people here have
medical imaging backgrounds but I kind
of want to bring you into the fold a
little bit so medical imaging we've all
heard about the things that we can do
it's really revolutionized how we do
medicine so we use it for screening we
use it for the primary diagnosis we do
treatment planning with it and we and we
finally monitor how well those
treatments performed we've got on this
page we've got a see that's a I think
that's an MRI here's a mammography
here's another MRI nuclear medicine a CT
these are all these different things
that you've heard about you probably
seen it on I don't know Grey's Anatomy
or I don't know what people watch these
days but it's an important part of
medicine and there's really two types of
medical imaging even though we have all
these different specific technologies we
can we can break it down a little bit
further more granular and we have an
atomic imaging and we have molecular
imaging so anatomic we only see anatomy
we use what's known as a contrast agent
something that you inject changes the
color a little bit and finally it what
that contrast agent does is it enhances
how the image looks it changes its
constituent which is a fancy word for it
changes this contrast and how well you
can see things and the contrast agents
are at the millimolar to micromolar
range primarily at the millimolar and
that's what we see an MRI and CT a whole
other type of medical imaging is
molecular imaging we don't see anatomy
so I forgot to give you some examples of
anatomic that's MRI that's CT as
ultrasound that's the dominant ones
there so molecular imaging we see a
tracer so a tracer is something that it
shows a function is so it shows it doing
something we don't see the anatomy at
all so for example in nuclear
Edinson will give an injection of a
tracer that will see a cancer that will
make it light up but you don't see the
rest of the body all you see is you know
actually you see you'll see the bladder
and then you'll see a cancer and you'll
see a few other things like things of
high activity maybe bone brain etc but
we don't see tissue now what we can do
is we can combine the two so here we
have something that sees function
nuclear medicine pet SPECT and then
we'll combine it with the CT scan so we
can see where it is in context and the
rest of the body so molecular imaging
and anatomic imaging there's a huge gulf
between the two but we can bring them
together these techniques are all built
on different principles whether it be
optical attenuation magnetic resonance
sound reflection or nuclear decay we
have four different ways of seeing into
the body three of them are anatomic and
one of them is molecular so all of these
different properties lead to anatomic
imaging and again over here is molecular
so now I get to introduce what we do so
we use what's known as magnetic particle
imaging which is a molecular imaging
technique we don't see tissue so what we
can see is an iron oxide tracer we
unambitious lycée here's an iron oxide
where is it in the body how much is in
there and something to remember is NPI
and MRI even though the names are pretty
similar have nothing to do with each
other we can't get an NPI scan on an MRI
machine so we do Clint a preclinical and
clinical imaging what we have right now
the physical system that we have
produced is for preclinical so I'm going
to talk about what we can use this
preclinical machine for but when you're
listening to this keep it in mind how we
might translate these very ideas into
imaging people which we'll be doing in
the next couple of years so here on the
Left we have an NPI in a CT overlaid
what we have is we in we've implanted
little iron oxide tracer bundles into
this animal and you see on the on this
animal we can tell that there's the same
amount of tracer under the skin right
over here we've also labeled this the
same tracer vials with an optic
tracer and the optical tracer if you
notice the signal changes dramatically
as we drop deeper into the tissue it
turns out optical imaging is the
dominant preclinical imaging technique
but we don't use it in the clinic
because we can't see deep into tissue
person here but my head is 10
centimeters to to the middle another 10
centimeters all the other other end and
here I can't even image you know 2
millimeters deep so we don't use optical
clinically and finally here's an MRI of
and it turns out all of these even
though they look very different are the
same animal so here we have two tracers
implanted optically we can see that
there's two different groups of tracer
although we can't really tell how much
there is and MRI it well it turns out
people will say MRI sees iron oxide well
it technically does but it really can't
quantitate it and here this is the
difference between an anatomic imaging
technique and a molecular imaging
technique I can't tell how much is there
in fact I can't even really find it
unless I knew where I put it so so it's
just there they're different classes
again so we can see through deep tissue
so for example here we have MPI going
further and further into tissue where as
an optical the signal drops very
dramatically we can see that the optical
signal drops exponentially which is
couldn't it's because of your Lambert's
law so it goes down exponentially
whereas MPI the signal we could image
through a human with no problem we've
used the technique for a number of
applications in in small animals we can
do cell tracking I'll talk more about
this one a little bit we can do blood
pool imaging where we're seeing how the
tracer is flowing through the blood in
real time we can also do say different
types of blood pool imaging here's TBI
imaging for example but before we get
there let's let's talk about how it
works because we're an engineering group
here and I would love to show you well
physically what's happening so suppose
we have two magnets these magnets are
pointing at each other
so you have the North Pole the North
Pole pointing to each other the two
magnets are pushing away and we get
these field lines that go through here
and this coming back to Maxwell's
equations well
the field lines diverge if this were an
MRI the field lines would go straight
this is the main magnetic field this is
the the primary thing in the middle of
that magnet and it's completely
different than what we do with existing
techniques at the very middle of that
magnetic field we have what's called the
field free point the field free point is
where the magnetic field passes through
zero and I'll show you a little bit more
about how that works in a little bit so
let's just take a closer look at that
field free point and the way that we
produce a signal is when we take that
field free point and we rapidly
translate it across an animal or a
patient it produces a signal and the way
produces a signal just this is a nano
particle right here and this down the
particle will tend to point at the field
free point and as we transition the nano
particle or the field free point over
the nano particle particle will flip to
follow the field free point and it it
will induce a signal blip in a receiver
coil which is shown in green over here
and then we have a little preamplifier
on the receiver coil so nothing too
special there so a little bit more in
depth if this right here is the field
free point and this right here is the
nano particle as the field free point
transitions over the nano particle we're
gonna see that that particle remains
aligned with the magnetic field lines
that's actually what's happening and
it's going from a positive Magna zation
to a negative Magnus a shipping in the
middle and as we flip in the middle
there we detect dm/dt the change of
magnetization over time and that right
there is a stable blip and that's the
point spread function of the system we
have a point source in we get a point
source image out let's see what happens
when we have multiple particles again
here's the field free point the field
free point we're going to transition
over these nano particles and the nano
particles one at a time
flip to follow the applied so the local
magnetic field and they flip flip flip
flip we go from a positive magn is a
Shinto a negative magnetic dm/dt over
there and there's our signal so in this
case we have a rect in I'm gonna get a
rect out pretty straightforward right so
fundamentally what's happening is we
have an animal we have a field free
point we transition the field free point
across the animal let's see that happen
and then we'll get sort of a character
stick image and so this particular
animal was injected with the liver
targeting tracer and has gone into the
liver so you see the liver and you also
see the spleen and it's overlaid on the
CT so the multi core nanoparticles are
the type of nanoparticles that we see so
multi core as well as single core and
I'll show you these two different
classes that we can we can image this
particular class of particles there's
commercial examples and most notably one
called rezerve it's which is a it's an
MRI tracer but it also produces a decent
MPI signal and it was first approved for
human use in about 2001 in Europe and is
still currently used in Japan so our
company internally we sell it as vivo
tracks for preclinical use in case any
of you want any then there's a whole
other classes of nanoparticles that we
can see so for example there's these
single core nanoparticles and the NPI
truly benefits from having cores that
are are customized to how MPI works so
there's so far the best cores are about
20 to 25 nanometers and these ones show
up fantastically we can get down to
about 400 micron resolution so the
physics of how the technique works is
that the resolution is related to the
volume of magnetic material in each core
so we can we can actually draw
resolution curves in relation to how the
gradient strength and the nanoparticle
interact so here let me let me is my
mouse here so the nanoparticle which is
these these contours interact the the
field gradient and if we say have a 6
Tesla per meter gradient which we've
built we get submillimetre resolution
when we have a 30 nanometer particle and
so all of this plays out in an actual
like in both in theory and an experiment
so this is a more engineering group so
usually I don't go through the hardware
but I can kind of go through what what
the instrumentation looks like so we
have a few basic steps to producing an
MPI image so first off we have to
produce a magnetic field and so we
produce either magnetic field free point
or in our case we typically make a field
free line so is that sense the point but
instead of having a
point where we're detecting the nano
magnetic or so the nano particles we
extend that into a line and just the
volume of that line is so much larger
than a point that our our sensitivity
goes up by about two orders of magnitude
so we'll produce one of these filled
free points using two large magnets and
then we get that that those flux lines
and finally the fields free point in the
middle what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take that field free point and we
need to be able to slowly translate it
across an animal so we got to slowly
translated across an animal the reason
we need to slowly do that is because the
change of magnetic field is so large
that we can't rapidly do that we're
talking about a time bearing field of
about point two Tesla we can buy MRI
machines for humans that are 0.3 Tesla
so we are time varying the strength of
one of these like lower field MRI
magnets it's a huge amount of power we
need to rapidly translate that field as
well so slow translation of this field
free point or field free line does not
produce a signal we have to move that
field free point or field free line at
about 1,500 meters per second we can
only do that electronically so we're
gonna shake it around real quick and
that's gonna induce the signal or
produce a signal from the nanoparticles
so they're gonna receive it with a
receiver coil and finally through a lot
of image processing we turn that signal
into an image so if this is the main
magnet there's a lot of other stuff
going on there's all sorts of filters
and all sorts of other things that are
happening within the machine and I'm not
going to really go over those because
that could take another hour but the
complexity is something that's very
important like well how complex is it
but we believe MPI is very comparable in
complexity - MRI but it's comparable in
different ways in MRI the hardest thing
to do is make that main magnet once you
make the mega magnet there's a lot of
other difficult things - but one of the
hardest engineering technical technical
difficulties is producing something
that's a part per million in accuracy
and the only way to do that is through a
lot of patient engineering and probably
about I'm thinking what 30 years of
physics research so in contrast MPI we
use part per million levels of harmonic
distortion so we're putting in say let's
see we're putting in about 6,000 watts
so
transmitted power and we're detecting
something in a nano watt range so we
have I think it was like 16 orders of
magnitude of power difference between
the input and output and we isolate that
through very careful filtering and so we
have to have part per level per million
levels of harmonic distortion to be able
to make that work and then finally the
costs are pretty comparable and we don't
we have you know shield rooms and all
sorts of other stuff like that so what
can we use
MPI for we have a number of different
applications that we're currently
developing internally and they range
from cell tracking and tumor imaging and
a few other ones and I'm just going to
go through cell tracking tumor imaging
and blood pool imaging and these other
ones I'm not going to talk about so this
work was done over at UC Berkeley when I
was still a researcher there with one of
one of the smartest people I've met over
the years dr. Zhang and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna demonstrate that using
all of this crazy technology that we can
track cells because it turns out there's
no good techniques for tracking cells
right now so we're going to do is we're
gonna start by labeling some Mazon Komal
stem cells and then we're gonna inject
them and longitudinally follow them for
about 12 days so simple experiment you
start with cells label them with reza
vez so that the iron oxide tracer that's
approved for use in humans and then
we're gonna eject with these different
animals and see what happens so
immediately after your injection here's
something that's pretty cool cells go
into the body and guess what they get
stuck they get stuck in the lungs so it
turns out we just built a million dollar
lung imager which is useful it turns out
but here we can see that the beautiful
lung is over there of this rats it's all
in 3d we can see what's happening there
but here's something that we cannot do
with existing techniques is twelve days
later where did all this tracer go so
they're just not going to sit in the
lungs because cells can move cells can
squeeze through things and there's no
tracer technology out there right now
that can last for 12 days except for
this because the inorganic nanoparticle
the body can break it down but the body
the body break down half-life is much
longer than twelve days but we can
actually extend it to as long as we want
and also shorten it if we want it to
break down and you know six hours so
it's because it's an inorganic particle
when we're detecting their magnetic
non-linearity a control experiment would
be like what happens we just inject the
tracer so immediately after injection we
see it just goes to the deliver over
there so we can also measure the
post-mortem distribution it's kind of
like scintigraphy where you take all the
other organs and lay them around and see
see what happens and it also lasts for
many months so so we've we've done the
same experiment in the brain for about
three months and there's many
applications for this for example if
we're doing a Parkinson's treatment we
will implant cells as the Parkinson
treatment these are some of the research
applications and well how many of those
cells are alive are they are they in the
right spot have they moved all these
sort of questions we can answer using
this sort of technology the signal is
also very linear i I never put r-squared
of one because I don't know if that's
technically possible so I always end up
having to go for many digits and then
with all of that the most important
thing it turns out is this next one it's
like here's how other techniques do the
same sort of cell tracking so NP I
immediately after injection we see went
to the lungs is pretty straightforward
here's something that's from literature
where people are tracking cells using
optical imaging and well they're in the
lungs and and this is what people use
the most in the research lab right now
it's it's just this one is a pretty
bulletproof way of doing it but it's non
quantitative it'll tell you it's in the
lungs but if you flip the animal over
the images look completely different so
it's just it's very difficult to use and
finally over there on spekt spective the
lungs the tracer only lasts for about
two days though after that the tracer
half-life is just a radioactive decay
has gone far enough down that you just
can't detect them anymore
so in summary MPI is quite good at cell
tracking but that's not all that we can
do so what we're gonna do here is
another bread-and-butter imaging of
medical imaging which is seeing if
people have cancer so this is from a
fantastic students Elaine's over at
Berkeley's still Mindy just went over to
MGH for for her PhD so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take a nude rat
so it's a immune-compromised rat and
implant to a tumor and it's going to
grow this tumor and then finally we're
going to see where this particular tumor
is so here's the sort of images that we
can get right here we see the rat we're
taking a slice right down the middle and
you see right over here we have this
tumor that's slowly collecting tracer
over time so immediately upon injection
you see that there's this ring
enhancement you see this ring around to
the tumor and what that ring comes from
is so if we have a rapidly growing tumor
and you have this tumor you have this
network of blood cells or sorry blood
capillaries around it and so there's
this blood volume and if you take a
slice through a ring or sorry the sphere
you get a ring so that's why that ring
is around there then over time these
nanoparticles are finding their way
slowly in to the tumor itself and this
is because these tumors can often have
very leaky blood vessels so these are
two different effects that were able to
visualize here if we take a look at the
six-hour time point we can see this is
when the most particles have found their
way into the tumor we can actually see
the image across the entire animal so
here we here we can see this is the
heart the livers over here here's the
spleen and guess what
tumors over here this is a different
animal and over the next few hours we
see that the tracer is being pulled out
of the blood by the liver and the spleen
and the tumor is also pulling just a
little bit of tracer out and so that we
believe this is about 2% of the total
injected dose around inside the tumor
and so the dynamic range of the
technique enables us to both see the the
liver as well as what's happening in
that tumor which is a very remarkable
for what we're being able to were able
to do here all of this is quantitative
so for example if we wanted to say how
much was in the tumor we can say those
sort of things and quickly moving on
here this is a type of
blood pool imaging that I'm talking
about here so when we're seeing into the
this blood coursing through the veins
through the tumor well what else can we
do with sort of blood pool imaging like
that well let's just do a quick example
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
take a standard normal animal it's got
nothing wrong with it and I'm just gonna
inject and see what happens so
immediately after injection it turns out
that we can get a pretty nice picture of
that of the brain so we inject a tracer
in remember we don't see tissue we only
see tracer so what we're seeing over
here is tracer in tissue we're seeing
blood that's coursing through tissue at
the capillary level we can also see it
you know up different levels in the
arteries and the veins so if you see you
over here you see this ghostly outline
you can see the teeth over here if you
wait for that to turn around it turns
out there's a lot of blood in the teeth
didn't expect to be able to see that
we're starting to be able to label some
of the internal arteries and veins and
then we can also see the external
arteries and veins so usually blood
comes in on the inside of the brain and
comes out on the outside the moment that
we're able to see blood well how about
can we see changes in blood flow over
time so what we're gonna do here is a
different sort of experiment we're gonna
give the body a stimulus and see if we
can make the blood vessels change so
this is a kind of like doing functional
MRI or functional imaging and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna give this
animal the same one actually a co2 so
carbon dioxide is a very potent
vasodilator and the reason is a potent
vasodilator is our that's part of our
body's regulatory system for when we
think really hard and then the blood
vessels open up more blood comes in and
that's a lot of what leads to say the
bold stimulate or the bold effect an MRI
or in our case this sort of effect so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna scan
that slice on that animal repeatedly
scan over and over and over again once
every eight seconds which is it's at a
good rate but we should be getting a
little bit faster than the near future
and we have two minutes of oxygen then
form
a mixture of oxygen co2 and then finally
back to pure oxygen so we're able to
start to see some of these different
brain structures so as the blood vessels
open we see that blood rushes in to the
animal brain and so to get everyone
oriented this is the animal brain the
trachea is over here we've got some ears
up here and we see the blood rushes into
the very middle of the brain but it's
got to go somewhere so you have all this
extra blood coming in and so that up
here we have a draining vein so I don't
know if you guys can see that over there
and so the blood sort of leaves the
brain and then we turn off the co2 and
everything goes back to normal so
there's a lot of different applications
for this and this is something that
we've been slowly leading towards in in
clinical medicine is well you know if we
can do say for example MRI can we use
fMRI functional MRI clinically and right
now it's very difficult to do
spunctional-- MRI clinically because the
snr is too low
whereas something like this yes and art
is much higher and we can quite possibly
use it clinically so I'm gonna just
change tracks and get back to some
hardware because we we have a lot of
Engineers in here and so that that was
my brief for wait for a into the
biomedical world but back to hard worth
this is the system that we've built to
do all of this and this is the momentum
imager and this install right here is
actually over just down the street over
here in the Clark center and so this is
the the first time that it's left the
laboratories over at UC Berkeley and as
part of the company we commercialize
this built a commercial ready product
and now we're testing it over here now
what's inside it so I have the pretty
outside and usually I don't show this
one so I'm showing it just to you guys
and apparently everybody online so this
is what's inside so the machine itself
weighs about 4,000 pounds about actually
is about five thousand four thousand of
it rotates so it's got a mechanical
rotation stage that spins this large
magnet around and let me show you what
that looks like so the animal goes in on
the right and then we spin the whole
magnet around it
to produce the signal we got a robot
chain at the left this this is all a RF
shield box so it's spinning the RF field
box around it so that we don't pick up
any external interference all of those
blue and red lines are water cooling
because we have a lot of power to do
this this is all on a laminated iron
return and it's straight out of high
energy physics this we use a lot of the
same manufacturer as well as the people
who manufacture than your accelerators
so it's it's quite a ordeal to get all
of this to work but leave we've got it
up and running here let me give you a
better tour of the different parts here
let's see so here we go so animal goes
in right here goes into the imaging
center of the board which is right over
here
you have these two magnets here's the
this is the I guess right magnet this is
the left magnet and these are the water
cooling lines and we run it like about
90 psi we've got the power lugs come in
there there's power over there and all
of that power is coming through this
robot chain along with all the water
this is a copper box that extends all
the way through here and the reason we
can have an open front is the entire
thing is built around a waveguide and so
external interference can't make it into
the center of the imaging more now the
unfortunate part with having a waveguide
is that we can't put anything metal in
the front or like I can't put a single
wire in because then it just conducts
all the noise in so everything up in the
front is built of glass so we have a
like ceramic rods and stuff over here
to be able to have a long cantilever
load out in the end without without
conducting any noise and so that's the
system and see and see that rotating
around again there we go
took a couple years and that's running
at
one fifth speed so when we run it at
full speed it should be able to do a
rotation in about three seconds so I
think it uses like a two horsepower
motor to spin it around so what it looks
like when we're trying to put it into
place is it just takes power and water
this was a business decision as opposed
to well like ideally if I could make any
choice that I wanted I would run it with
a you know either a superconducting
magnet or other thing that I can get to
much higher fields but as a business
decision we we made it very simple to
site we use 480 volts and we use a lot
of water these are things that typical
universities have especially in their
their medical imaging and it takes a
pretty modest footprint about 15 foot by
15 foot so it would fit up here in fact
we when we installed it over at the
Stanford site this is a service corridor
so this is a service corridor for their
MRI so if they ever need to move their
MRI then we move ours into the hallway
they put the memory out and we've cars
beckon we've written all of the software
to do to do all of this and we hide
pretty much all the complexity well our
typical user is a biologist and
something that we've we've told our
users and something we very very much
believe to use a system like this is
very simple it's to understand what's
happening it's like you see the iron
that that's what we can do now I don't
tell them how we see it because if we
got into the math it was gonna it's
gonna blow their mind but we have one
click and it takes an image gives it in
a DICOM and then I can they can like
link it up with whatever they're working
on it's it's turned out to be wonderful
because we're not we're also not having
to support their use of the system
because they understand
you hit the button you get you get where
the iron is in the body so what the user
ends up seeing is they they just they
hit start and the robot goes in the
animals at the end of the cantilever and
that's pretty much the user experience
for most of this stuff
we're able to demonstrate ably show
submillimetre resolution now so with
nanoparticles tailored to MPI we're
seeing down to about 400 micron
resolution so if we have to point
sources getting closer and closer
together down to about 400 microns were
able to resolve them it turns out it's
more difficult to get to point sources
close to 400 microns apart than it is to
actually image it so the best we can get
so far is about 600 microns spacing of
our point sources the signal is also
completely linear again we keep on
redoing these linearity tests to make
sure that we haven't broken anything in
the reconstruction and we're linear over
four orders of magnitude which is very
remarkable for medical imaging it's not
something that we typically see we're
also very sensitive so here we are
detecting particles in this vial that if
you look in the light there's absolutely
no color in it so here we are at about
10 micromolar of concentration and for
for numbers as 550 picograms of iron per
microliter we're talking picogram range
it's just these are just minuscule trace
amounts we talked about let's see water
contamination in nano grams I mean
that's in per you know per liter and
stuff like that so the snr also scales
down to as we get smaller and smaller
vials and so here's here's a vial that's
roughly at the resolution limit of the
system here we are about millimeter by a
millimeter and we have 1.1 nano grams of
iron in here and so when we're talking
about nano grams of iron in a sample and
then we still see it with a decent SNR
so our detection limit is again in the
picogram range so that's firmly what we
do in nuclear medicine or in our case
MPI so we're kind of getting into this
very similar to other tracer imaging
modalities so anyhow with that I think I
had 40 minutes right so here's a lot of
things that we do and give me some
questions please
yes so is your primary like market going
to be researchers or many possibilities
so so this is a when people talk about
bootstrapping this is not usually how
they talk about bootstrapping but this
is our bootstrap market so the
technology in MPI is pretty complex as
you might guess so we started in 2004
sorry about Shay 2005 we started in 2005
and it took us until about 2014 to be
ready to spin out the company over that
time me and my old PA Steven Connolly he
used to be here at Stanford for 20 years
we raised about 12 million from the NIH
to get us to that spot so here we spun
it out and we're like well to launch a
clinical product we'd have to raise a
hundred million and that's the usual
number that people bandy about and it's
pretty true it might be a little bit
more for capital equipment but the
preclinical research market well that
one in relative terms is much smaller in
terms of the capital requirements so
this is our bootstrap market and all the
technology that we've developed right
now you know to date we're transitioning
of that into our clinical product so all
of the software all of the control
systems all of the hardware is just
going to get scaled up gets pretty big
though but we had to get it working
first I would say I had very good
training so it was as you guys are in
grad school it was all about my advisor
so I just he trained me it was and so at
Steve
so he's been at Berkeley for I guess 12
years now before that he was here at
Stanford for I think 20 20 plus years
and he was working for Al makovski so al
al was one of the I guess just leaders
in medical imaging and so Steve was
trained by Al and so you know by proxy I
mean this is this is how the
these sort of the sinologist gets passed
along and I can't say enough about my
old advisor
more questions yeah so you said it cost
about a hundred million dollars usually
yeah
are you looking for like DC funding
after you finish your course Jack market
or yes yes yes as so we're headed down
that path right now yeah
so the we're able to raise much less
money as well so the the whole idea
behind a bootstrap market is that we
have steady income coming in and the
steady income keeps us from in you see
policies from getting desperate so so
we're we're building a true company for
small animal imaging and then we're
going to just transition all that
technology to the human side but the
amount of time it takes to build these
things it's just a different timeline
than a lot of people are used to just
because they're so big and so we just
want to be safe on the way sure so the
the sales cycle is is a very interesting
one so we're selling to researchers and
scientists so researchers at
institutions like Stanford and
scientists at places like I'm just
picking a pharma company for example
like Genentech or a lot of these like
people working on car t-cells and
there's there's just a lot of Pharma out
there so the typical sales cycle is we
we it's a relationship cell and so we
know people and our our customers are
sorry our our sales people we just have
a lot of we just see them as colleagues
in the different institutions and we're
selling to people that we know and we
care about and hopefully they care about
us too but we're giving them something
that enables a whole different field of
research for them something that they I
I believe they need a lot and so we're
selling it through relationship we've
got a we've got a couple sales guys
right now
and that's just the typical sales
process so as business-to-business sales
it's not manat spamming people sort of
thing we don't we don't really cold call
it's a it's a very involved one so so
the the sales cost is about six hundred
and fifty thousand and that's about the
price of it I think a Lamborghini or
something right
so I put golden doors on it just because
I could yes
it didn't actually show you guys so
these these pop up the whole wings I
couldn't resist but the sales costs 50k
so for a long time I've been doing a lot
of and I don't know if you guys have
done this one a lot of business plan
competitions just because it's fun sorry
I when I was here at Stanford I think I
did it I think three times when I went
to Cal I did a couple times and one one
time we won the their whole business
plan competition but those were all
different projects it wasn't actually
this project at this particular project
by the time that I was ready to
commercialize it I had totally burnt out
and so this one just kind of fell in my
lap in some sense but it was a whole
career of working towards that spot to
be ready for it
I'm feeling worse what is a life like
and the CEO what you're looking for is
for you
ah so that's a great question so what's
my life like it in my position well I'm
in a tiny company so most of the time
I'm you know at a lab bench or building
stuff or running around and and trying
to raise money and as I continue to grow
the company me and the CEO we're having
to pull ourselves away a lot from the
day-to-day of you know putting nuts to
bolts and try to do more the strategic
direction but I'm small enough right now
that I got it I still got a lot of have
have a lot of fun but as we continue to
grow I'm gonna get pulled more and more
out of that
what advice would you have for someone
who is doing a PhD and is possibly
interested in startups but like we don't
necessarily have the time to in many
ways balance our to think about the the
bigger picture in our research like in
my case the example so what advice would
I have for someone who's interested in
this stuff but doesn't necessarily have
the time for so that's an interesting
question I I don't I don't know where to
go or to go with that one it's more of a
I I would say just keep it as a mindset
the the way to either find your way into
your own startup or to find your way
into a another group of people who are
doing something together is just lots of
talking people are wonderful and the
interesting thing about startups is it's
all just people all of the people that
we've we pulled in and hired it's all
because they're they're a cultural fit
they have this wonderful background and
the only way that we run across them is
just through friends of friends the the
cold the cold you know resume list the
seldom do much it's just it's all about
people
yeah so I guess that would be my my
recommendation just talk to everyone
anything else thank you
[Applause]
you